a lot of times you don't know what your
competitive advantage is when you launch
a new product okay so if you want to
lose the perfectionist gene you want to
actually make some progress with your
business I'm gonna give you the three
ways to do it the thing that makes
individuals really really special who
are that great is they're always looking
for that competitive edge
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message create a competitive
advantage over to you Steve Jobs also if
you want to learn from Steve Jobs and
other entrepreneurs on how to build
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below I say well I think you
should go get a job as a busboy or
something till you find something you're
really passionate about
we came up with the software called next
step which lets you build apps five to
ten times faster than anything anyone
has ever seen and after you build them
they're deployable and usable by mere
mortals because it's really easy to use
this computer and you can interoperate
your custom apps seamlessly with a bunch
of off-the-shelf productivity apps so we
go to these companies that use Suns and
take two years to write their apps or
thinking about using sense and they can
write their apps in about 90 days on the
next now if you're on wall street and
you can write you can create a new
product in 90 days versus your
competitor in two years that's eight new
products you can field for there every
one and you can start to see the
competitive advantage that can be
created this way now we had no idea that
we were any good at this when we started
next a lot of times you don't know what
your competitive advantage is when you
launch a new product when we did the
Macintosh we never anticipate a desktop
publishing when we created the Mac
sounds funny because that turned out to
be the Mac's compelling advantage right
the thing that it did not one and a half
or two times better than everything else
but you know four or five times better
than anything else where you had to have
one we never anticipated it we
anticipated bitmap displays and laser
printers but we never thought about
PageMaker that whole industry really
coming down to the desktop maybe we
weren't smart enough but we were smart
enough to see it start to happen nine to
twelve months later and we changed our
entire marketing and business strategy
to focus on desktop publishing and it
became the Trojan horse that eventually
got the Mac into corporate America where
it could show its owners all the other
wonderful things you could do likewise
when we created next step this
revolutionary object-oriented software
that we have our target customer coming
from the PC world where shrink-wrapped
apps were king was Lotus and Adobe in
WordPerfect in all the shrink-wrap apps
developers and the purpose was to let
them create their apps 5 to 10 times
faster these shrink-wrapped apps and it
worked we have a ton of shrink-wrapped
apps now on Vesta breed in almost every
category
but it wasn't till early and 91 early
last year little over a year ago that
some really big companies came to us and
said you don't understand what you've
got the same software that allows Lotus
to create their apps five to 10 times
faster is letting us build our in-house
mission-critical apps five to ten times
faster and this is the biggest problem
we've had this is a huge problem for
every big company and almost all
medium-sized companies and you have the
solution in your hands and you dummies
don't even know it and it took him about
three months before we finally heard and
in last summer we changed our whole
sales and marketing strategy around to
focus on that it's taken off like a
rocket and we grew about 4x last year
and probably grow about 2x this year and
our customer list is is now very very
strong and growing like crazy we just
got back from spending a few days in DC
and in New York and we're talking to
customers we only dreamed of talking to
a year ago stop trying to be perfect one
of the biggest things that holds
entrepreneurs back is you have an idea
in your head and you want to launch it
but you're afraid to launch anything
until it's perfect you're afraid to put
anything out into the world until you
have the perfect plan the perfect
product the perfect competitive
advantage and that does not exist and
the biggest danger of all is that just
stays an idea for you for the rest of
your life that it never actually gets
created because you can never reach
perfection because you're afraid of
releasing the thing out into the world
and so you never will where everybody
who you look up to the people who've had
massive success any entrepreneur they
release something before it was perfect
they got feedback they adjusted they
listened to it and that became the thing
that propelled them to massive success
and so you need to move from that place
of trying to have everything be a
hundred percent perfect before you
launch and just get used to actually
creating at
we doing actually putting stuff out
there into the market instead of sitting
on your couch hoping wishing dreaming
planning strategizing but never actually
doing so we see that in Steve Jobs here
he thought he was launching one thing he
thought it was great he thought it was
genius but by being in the market he
realized oh I actually should be doing
this thing I look at my youtube channel
the same way the top ten series the ant
spresso series go back on my channel
this is not what I was doing at the very
beginning there were seeds event it was
still about inspiring entrepreneurs is
still about Marlin success but how I
change and evolve and the thing that
ended up blowing up my channel was not
the thing that I started with but the
key was that we start we release its
crap at the beginning and we make it
better and we tweak and we improve and
the quantity leads to the quality but if
I sat at home and planned and planned
and planned and planned I would still be
at home planning instead of having a
channel with 1.5 million subscribers and
building a team and impacting millions
of people around the world you need to
get off your couch you need to get out
of your head and start creating okay so
if you want to lose the perfectionist
gene you want to actually make some
progress with your business I'm gonna
give you the three ways to do it number
one be stubborn on the Y and flexible in
the how the Y needs to be important why
are you doing the thing that you're
doing needs to be important needs to be
more than just making money there's some
mission that you're on and accomplishing
that mission is is the thing is what's
coming out of your heart and needs to be
exploded to the world but how you get
there is gonna take a million different
twists we're I think too many
entrepreneurs fixate on having the
perfect how whether you don't recognize
that that how is gonna change a thousand
times it will change a thousand times
and when you get fixated on just having
that one he'll be exactly this way you
lose so for me I want to try to solve
the world's greatest about them I want
to I want to untap human potential and
right now I think the best execution of
that is YouTube but it likely won't be
you too
maybe in two years maybe in five years
maybe in ten years right I'm playing
with Instagram I'll get into VR when it
comes out I'll get into Evan robots or
believe BOTS or whatever comes out that
can have my mission help me accomplish
it that's what I'm gonna be doing even
within the YouTube framework I've
adjusted so many times on the formatting
of my videos and the topics that I cover
and so that is that is essential is
you're thinking about it how can I be
stubborn on the why I'm stubborn on this
is the reason why I wake up every day
and grind in my business because I have
a mission that I'm on but how you go
about accomplishing it you are open you
are flexible you're taking input from
everywhere to try to make the best
version in the year that you're in right
now to win number two is used a 595 rule
spend five percent of your time planning
and ninety-five percent of your time
doing five percent of your time planning
and ninety-five percent of your time
doing this is the ratio that needs to
change for you because most people are
maybe not quite flipped or it's 95
percent planning five percent doing but
it's pretty close so how do you tell the
difference
planning is just ideas it's in your head
it's researching it's strategizing is
trying to solve problems just thinking
thinking thinking it's really important
because if you don't have any plenty and
you're just off doing your gonna run
around in circles and never get anything
done but the results come from the doing
the doing is greeting emails and doing
is creating content the doing is making
your product the doing is talking to
customers the doing is going to trade
shows the doing is making youtube videos
like doing the doing is making your
product at doing the duelling the doing
the doing the doing the doing to doing
the doing the doing to doing to doing to
doing five percent of your time planning
ninety-five percent of your time doing
you need to shift that equation if you
just did that alone the amount of work
that you would get done would be
staggering if you did that for the next
year your life would be unrecognizable
from where it is today because of all
the action that you are doing shifted
the 595 rule 5%
time planning ninety-five percent of
your time doing look at your schedule
look at your calendar see how you're
spending this week see how you spent
today so far see how you're gonna spend
the next month look at your calendar and
make sure you're spending ninety five
percent of your time actually doing
something and number three is connect
with a customer Delian I want part of
your doing to connect with customers or
potential customers every single day
just to understand them to understand
their world if you know that you're
gonna start you're gonna have an idea
it's not gonna be perfect we're gonna
launch something that's not perfect how
do you get it to be perfect how do you
get it closer to that perfection is by
talking to customers is by understanding
their world successful businesses come
when you match what you love to do with
what there isn't demand for what the
market wants combine those two things
together that's when you win so if you
are selling software and a piece of
software costs 50 bucks for you as an
example as a sale price you may say it's
not worth my time to spend a day diving
in with my customer to understand their
business and ways they're only paying me
50 bucks what's the point when is the
education because that customers problem
is every customers problem I'm building
up my youtube channel what I do is as
part of my daily routine I check out
what you guys are doing on YouTube I'm
amped up pumping up my Instagram account
I had my best month ever last month and
I'm growing it growing and growing it
how do I learn I'm paying attention to
what you guys are creating on Instagram
- I painted tension - the problems that
you are facing the problems that you're
asking me on my live videos why do I go
live four times a week on Instagram to
get the feedback to understand your
issues to help me create better content
for you and so every single day I need
you to connect with a customer whether
that is going to meet them face to face
whether that's going to an event insane
high whether that's going into their
business and understanding their
operations whether that's following them
on social media and see where the
posting like every single day you are
connecting with the customer if you get
tight with your customers if you deeply
understand what their problems are and
you can match that with a solution that
you love the process of creating that
solution
you have hit a home run and so the last
one in 5% planning 95% doing as part of
your 95 percent doing everyday connect
with a customer now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
question of the day I want to know what
are you going to do to apply the 595
rule how are we going to up what you are
actually doing and creating let me know
put it down in the comments below
the thing that makes individuals really
really special who are that great is
they're always looking for that
competitive edge so it's interesting to
see how a champion in sports how it
relates to a champion in business it's
the same mindset it's about winning the
battles continuing to improve learning
new ways to stay ahead stay ahead of the
game
clarity is what gives you the idea of
success being able to close those deals
when you can see and you can think and
you can react with a clear mind and your
take your emotions out of it you're in
that zone getting the deal is just it's
just a byproduct and the minute you get
the deal you're already thinking about
what's next now quickly define moats in
terms of business that keeps the
competition away well you know if you
talk to Michael Porter he would give you
five books on what is meant by you know
strategy and competitive advantage and
durable competitive advantage and if you
talk to Warren and Charlie they would
just say it's a moat and they'd break it
down to one one word but basically it's
the ability of a business to have some
type of an some type of an enduring
competitive advantage that allows it to
earn a better than average rate of
return over an extended period of time
and so some businesses have narrow moats
some have broad modes
some have modes that are deep but get
filled up pretty quickly so what you
want is a business that has a deep moat
with lots of piranhas in it and that's
getting deeper by the day that's that's
a great business raise your standard
Apple at the core is core values
is that we believe that people with
passion can change not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
supposed to mean if you guys want to
learn more from Steve Jobs check out the
top ten rules of success video that I
did on him it is the most popular video
on my channel and there's a reason for
that the link to watch is right next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there once you learn that you'll never
be the same again